the other thing i want to say is that
i was mostly angry at him that he wasn't
around
by the time i got because i i
you know i was he was around for my
second season and i was in 10 out of 22
episodes of that the third season i was
in one episode but i see eastern four
when i became a cast regular and was
around all the time he was off doing
angel
and by the time i was on angel he was
off doing firefly so
he was never i he never saw and this is
the thing though this is why i was mad
because when he did come around and and
and direct an episode
i i i was never in it
i was like the musical well that is yeah
i had a couple of scenes in that i think
i had two scenes in that but often times
i was i i knew that i'd have the most
time off if joss was directing for some
reason when he came on i just wasn't
very much part of do you think he didn't
like you that's what i thought that's
what i was just like do you still think
that do you still think he never liked
you no not not anymore no no uh it's
just that i think that his mind went to
the original conception of the show
which was his
scooby gang going through
uh machinations and overcoming things
and that you know i'm a purist by nature
as well so i understand that his mind
kind of goes back to the right
kind of thing uh but at the time i was
like
you know
so the truth is there was a lot that
went on that i that i that i didn't see
really you just didn't see it you you
hear about things probably yeah and the
thing is that that that spike usually
spike's storyline was kind of like a
miniature movie within the other movie
within the main movie it was a subplot
so most of my scenes were with guest
stars
i didn't have that many you know
i had scenes with the other cast members
certainly but but not all the time a lot
of times it was it was with
another cast telling a separate story
would you do a buffy uh reunion if they
did something
or a buffalo movie you know if if jo
yes if
i i i have i have
i have reticence about it mike because
you know spike is a vampire and i'm not
you know oh spike looks really good for
his age that's that's not what you talk
about a vampire like what the great
scene would be buffy and spike get back
together and spike looks exactly like he
did back in the show but they haven't
they have makeup you can look a little
younger they you could look they could
use things for
you know i mean you still look damn good
but you're not like you know it's no
you're not 20 years ago i know but i
mean that's that would that would be
amazing to see buffy
with that one like spike's still
beautiful and buffy has aged like that
is that's a great scene but that's sort
of what would happen in the vampire
world right the vampire stays young yes
yes look at that sleep all day party all
night yeah grow old never die it's fun
to be a vampire and to take and take any
of that away from a vampire character is
to diminish them so i'm that's my
reticence that's why i'm kind of like